entrée en gare du train varsovie berlin
toutes les deux heures des centaines de
réfugiés ukrainien arrivent dans la
capitale allemande épuisé mais soulagé
au sous sol un millier de bénévoles se
relaie pour les accueillir leur donner à
boire à manger et le strict nécessaire
sur leurs visages le soulagement après
des jours d'exode mais aussi le
déchirement pour ces ukrainiens qui
comme julia et evgenia ont quitté leur
patrie et parfois leurs familles sous
les bombes
il y en a vraiment
aidé
[Musique]
des billets de train gratuits sont
distribués à ceux qui veulent poursuivre
leur route des bus également pour ceux
qui vont retrouver de la famille en
france
dans le nord de la ville les plus
démunis trouveront un logement d'urgence
dans le centre d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile 900 personnes ils sont déjà
hébergé
relatif nitrique niveau
[Musique]
dans la capitale allemande les autorités
se disent en mesure d'accueillir 20000
personnes dans les jours à venir mais ce
centre d'accueil à berlin est déjà
quasiment au bout de ses capacités
dix mille réfugiés de guerre sont
arrivés ce vendredi à berlin